head football coach Dion Sanders
commonly referred to as coach Prime
stunned the college football World on
Saturday as his team upset number 17
ranked TCU last year's National
runner-up in a 45-42 shootout in Fort
Worth when you see a confident black man
sitting up him talking his talk walking
his walk coaching 75 African-Americans
in the locker room that's kind of
threatening
oh they don't like that but guess what
we're going to consistently do what we
do because I'm here and ain't going
nowhere and I'm about to get comfortable
in a minute yeah I don't think anyone is
watching football and going uh uh too
many black people are playing this I
don't see all these black people that's
probably not happening